hi there in this sample I will
demonstrate how to create an apogee
integrated developer portal for your API
product
apogee's integrated developer portal is
a built-in solution where developers can
learn about and test your apis it serves
as the central hub for your API
consumers and is incredibly easy to
provision
before we begin be sure to read the
intro sections and note the
prerequisites you'll be able to follow
along with the instructions either in
Cloud shell or right here in this
repository in this video we'll follow
along with the cloud Shell let's get
started
this will download the apogee samples
GitHub repository code into your Cloud
shell editor
first we need to CD into the correct
folder
next update the environment file with
your own apogee information
then Source your environment file
if needed you can ensure that you are
signed into the correct account with
this command
now this is where it gets interesting
run this command to deploy the API proxy
and product
note however that this command will not
create your developer portal we will
have to do that separately and manually
once that finishes we'll navigate to the
next page and follow the instructions
there
on the next page in the tutorial click
on the link in Step 1 to access the
apogee console to create your portal
make sure that you are in the correct
apogee organization before clicking into
publish and then portals
click get started
use the name sample integrated developer
portal and select create
you'll soon be redirected to the home
configuration page for your new
developer portal
but our portal needs apis let's add them
now navigate to the API catalog page and
click the plus symbol to add an API to
your portal choose your own API product
give it a description and make sure that
it's published you can leave most of the
settings as they are but you'll want to
add open API API documentation
foreign
can be found back at in your Cloud shell
editor so navigate there now
download the integrated
developerportal.yaml file its content
was updated while running the deploy
script to reflect your apody domain
navigate back to your apogee Tab and
upload the yaml file that you just
downloaded
scroll up and save your portal API
now that we've got our portal set up and
ready to go let's test it in the top
right corner of this page you'll notice
a button that says live portal click it
once inside your portal click sign in
next click create an account
enter in your personal information your
email address will be sent a
confirmation link so make sure that it
is capable of receiving email
go to that email and click the
confirmation Link in order to enable
your developer account
note creating your account here will
also create a developer account in
apogee as well
upon opening the link from your
confirmation email you'll be redirected
back to your portal home page where
you'll once again need to sign in
after you do that click on your account
to open the drop down menu and select
apps
on the next page click plus new app
you can name your app sample app and be
sure to enable your API product before
clicking save note creating an app here
also creates an app and apogee as well
next navigate to your apis page and
select your API
click the authorize button and on the
pop-up select your sample app from the
drop down menu this will authorize any
request we make from the portal with an
API key from the app that we just
created
after this
click the forward slash get path this
represents an endpoint in the proxy we
just applied earlier
once you click execute you should see a
200 message that means that the request
was a success
let's navigate back to our Cloud shell
window
now that we've gone through all the
steps to create our developer portal and
to test it out you could optionally
delete the resources that we've created
in this sample by following the steps
below
first we'll manually delete the
resources that we manually created so
back in the apogee console navigate to
the developers page and delete the
developer account that you created
earlier next navigate to the portals
page and delete the portal that we
created earlier
enter delete
and finally
go back to the cloud shell window and
run the cleanup script to delete the
resources that our deploy script created
at the beginning of this sample
thank you for watching I hope this video
is useful to you if you have not signed
up for apogee yet use the top link if
you have any questions please visit the
apogee community